all right sunday surprise draft time
chris i'll let you have the first pick
okay um what was i going to go with my
sunday first pick i'm totally flustered
here because i wasn't expecting to go
there uh i think i'm going to hold on
hold on hold on i know i got a sunday so
oh here it is i wrote it down what the
hell am i doing the saints defense
that's going to be my sunday surprise
yes the lack of game plan or
anything for jaylen hurts and what he
brings to the table i think that's what
i'm shocked by you know just watching
there yesterday you know some of the
drop back pass scrambles things like
that there seemed to be no thought of
jalen hurts running or we need to have a
game plan for that more of just
hey we're just going to treat him like
every other drop back quarterback in
football well no
you can't because he's a lot dang more
dangerous than any other drop back
quarterback in football i just think
overall just the way that game played
out the fact that philadelphia ran the
ball controlled the clock did all those
type of things uh and jalen hurts won
that game with the saints defense that's
been
you know great
great as of late
that was probably the biggest surprise
of sunday to me
you know it's it's hard as we get deeper
into the season because there isn't much
left to surprise us the trends are
playing out for the most part and i
usually don't do this but i'm gonna go
to that same game because to me the
surprise was that jalen hurts played
well we had been conditioned to believe
that nothing was going to work we had
openly
speculated on the possibility that
they're putting jalen hurts into the
lineup so he can fail and everyone in
philadelphia can shut the hell up about
carson wentz jason kelsey last week
those comments that were riveting about
how it's a total failure by the players
by the coaches by everyone made me think
there was not a damn thing they could do
to make that offense any better well
surprised billy
jalen hurts
made it better and i didn't expect it i
thought it was part of the setup to
justify going back to carson wentz next
year they got a problem now maybe a good
problem yeah but they got a problem
because hertz
demands based upon his performance
yesterday more opportunities to keep
playing definitely you know
you know i
i don't think they were like
hey we're gonna fail with jalen hurst
and show everybody but i think they
thought if that's the possibility okay
this is the good thing that happens then
people will stop talking about that but
you're right this has opened up a can of
worms now and we're gonna see where it
goes you know because wha what does
happen if he continues to look the way
he did yesterday and they win football
games man that's gonna so you know start
some crap storm there in philadelphia as
far as the off season is concerned and
talk radio and all of that so uh i'm
with you that was that was shocking in a
lot of ways um i think the next one i'm
gonna go to
uh
i hate to do it just mahomes three
interceptions i i think that's shocking
to me i don't know that's the to me one
of the biggest surprises of the weekend
patrick mahomes
has he he's never had a three
interception game has he i don't even
know graham's game the rams game the 50
sports being in new mexico right that
game six touchdowns three picks okay so
other than that yes i've never you know
seen that before so that was a shocker
and not like hey i'm confused or i got
tricked by coverage one was a screen
pass which you know was there was trash
and chaos all around it ball got tipped
in the air by a miami defender he
usually doesn't make those type of
decisions then tries to hit clyde
edwards hilaire on a little check down
the next drive and throws it you know
above his head to where he can barely
get a hand on it that ends up being an
interception and then the the late
interception in the in the fourth
quarter you know he's got like we talked
about earlier he's got tyreek hill open
if he throws it out there he's going to
score a touchdown but he kind of under
throws it that's just rare it's rare it
didn't matter they still win he's still
amazing but um just don't see him throw
three picks too much
i'm going to go back to something we
talked about earlier because it deserves
to be highlighted again hassan reddick
five sacks that was a surprise to
everyone including to him he didn't know
until after the game that he had five
sacks he became very emotional he still
couldn't process that it had happened it
was a great day a career day for hassan
reddick with his five sacks something no
one would have predicted going into
yesterday's games no uh definitely not
that the other game had a few surprises
for sure i mean that
uh the way they just kind of pushed
around the giants offensive line who
just came off a week of where they just
pushed around the seattle seahawks and
did some dominant things there
and you know i was even gonna daniel
jones and the giants was just one of the
surprises to me i mean just with his
health the way they looked all of that
uh certainly certainly an issue all
right um
my last surprise
i think is paul gunther getting fired
after the game i mean i think you know i
hate to talk about football but
i mean uh talk go away from football
there but that's a shocker i don't know
what else to say i mean damn the raiders
are in the middle of the afc playoff
chase right now and they got a game on
thursday night and yeah they just got
their butts whipped by the indianapolis
colts and you know uh
rivers and the running game had their
way but just still like surprised that
they
gonna fire the defensive coordinator at
this point of the season right now to me
that that that certainly makes the draft
i am currently and i was texting while
you were talking because i am trying to
find out exactly what it is
that happened was there salty language
was there pushing and shoving was there
a jerry seinfeld george costanza slap
fight between rudin and gunther these
are things we must find out and we shall
because it is weird to do it chris with
a game coming up in just three days from
now when they take on the chargers with
their season on the line and look at
that plummeting of the playoff
probability from 45 down to 26 all right
the last one for me and again i got i
got to give him credit
mitchell trubisky good who would have
thought that he would outplay
one of the guys that the bears
could have had and i know he's got to be
sick of hearing it bears fans are sick
of hearing about it mitchell trubisky at
this point
trying to
create some film that maybe someone else
will see and say we can get more out of
this guy right than what matt and aggie
got out of this guy because trubisky on
track to be a free agent they didn't
pick up his fifth year option they're
not going to apply the franchise tag
barring something incredibly unlikely at
this point like trubisky leading them to
the playoffs and winning a game or two
he's going to be on the market so
everything he does the rest of the way
is trubisky showing the rest of the nfl
maybe you should take a chance on me for
next year not necessarily to be handed
the starting job but given a chance to
compete somewhere right maybe he can get
it done in the right offense maybe he
can get it done yeah maybe yeah no
if i didn't pick the paul gunther thing
that was going to be my pick too true
biscuit i'm glad you did it because that
was you know either way as bad as the
texans defense is we didn't expect the
bears offense to look like that trubisky
had that day compared to watson so
you're you're absolutely right and good
for him gets some people off his back at
least for a few days
all right you got one more there bro oh
no you got three and i got oh no
hey hey you stopped texting and trying
to find out why the raiders fired the
demons a coordinator pay attention to
the show over here all right you've
chosen focus get your game changed
i thought you had one more i was laying
out so you could go ahead
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports